hace unas semanas este pueblo pintoresco
de la costa del norte de italia fue el
epicentro de una polémica que sacude la
iglesia católica
ocurrió cuando el padre giulio se negó a
dar la tradicional bendición del domingo
de ramos un gesto de protesta contra el
documento publicado por la poderosa
congregación para la doctrina de la fe
en el vaticano responde a una pregunta
precisa la iglesia dispone del poder
para bendecir uniones de personas del
mismo sexo
la respuesta fue categórica no
el documento declara ilícita toda forma
de bendición a las parejas homosexuales
pues afirma que dios no bendice y no
puede bendecir el pecado son palabras
que hieren a las personas homosexuales
que hacen parte de la iglesia la iglesia
bendice todo tipo de cosas hasta las
armas y por el contrario no podemos
bendecir un amor verdadero sincero y
profundo porque se expresa en una pareja
homosexual
la iglesia debería dar estas bendiciones
para enviar un mensaje de apertura y de
apertura
[Música]
un mensaje de apertura que el padre
giulio comparte durante sus misas
frecuentadas por una parte de los casi
300 habitantes del pueblo
el que ama sin importar quien sea fue
creado por dios y conoce a dios
porque dios es amor
a las afueras de la parroquia el tema
hace reaccionar a los fieles no entiendo
como dos personas que se aman pueden
perjudicar a alguien la iglesia no
debería bendecir el mal pero si esas
personas no hacen ningún mal
entonces por qué no darles la bendición
a la iglesia católica no puede dar esas
bendiciones porque si el antiguo
testamento que sólo establece uniones
entre un hombre y una mujer y colgó
mcdonald y creo que es contraproducente
para la iglesia porque eso aleja a las
personas de la religión y de la iglesia
la diócesis local convocó al padre julio
y no excluyo posibles sanciones
disciplinarias
una posibilidad que hizo reaccionar a
los parroquianos como alexandra
cuando se enteró lanzó una petición en
redes sociales bautizada no toquen al
padre julio más de 10.300 personas la
han firmado y se la enviamos a la obispo
local pidiéndole que no sancionará al
padre julio entre las personas que
firmaron la petición también había
obispos y algunos prelados de la iglesia
siete personas de la que existe esa
prelados moderados que se oponen al
núcleo duro conservador y
tradicionalista de la iglesia
marco políti vaticanista para el la
publicación del documento de la
congregación para la doctrina refleja
las maniobras internas en el vaticano
ante la perspectiva de elección del
próximo papá
hay una lucha política en el interior de
la iglesia la batalla en el tema de la
bendición de las parejas del mismo sexo
hace parte de la batalla por el próximo
comprado para determinar el perfil del
próximo papá
[Música]
y recibí subterráneo el interior de la
iglesia está en pleno desarrollo
[Aplausos]
a pesar de estas luchas de poder
internas francisco reitera la
importancia de acompañar e integrar a
las minorías homosexuales en la iglesia
siete años después de su famosa frase si
una persona es gay quién soy yo para
juzgarla tenemos que acoger a aquellos
que están en situaciones de
vulnerabilidad
hoy por hoy no es inusual que el papá se
reúna con miembros de la comunidad
homosexual como andrea pareja de darío
desde hace 35 años católicos
practicantes son padres de tres hijos
por supuesto que me encantaría tener
algún tipo de reconocimiento una
bendición para poder celebrar nuestra
relación con nuestra comunidad de fe con
la comodidad y fe de la raza de la
acción
un deseo compartido por miles de parejas
homosexuales católicas en el mundo